[Musik]
wenn das nicht gut
ich bin hier die küchenchefin und die
inhaberin im restaurant strandhaus mein
name ist günther grothe wall e und ich
arbeite als restaurantleiter hier im
restaurant strand
der gast steht hier immer im mittelpunkt
und das ist halt wichtig dass die leute
zudem zum gast einfach offen und
freundlich sind es kommt natürlich auch
sehr sehr viel fachwissen noch dazu
[Musik]
ein ganz normaler arbeitstag im
restaurant beginnt restaurantfachmann
günther kümmert sich um den gästeraum in
der küche haben die vorbereitungen für
das essen angefangen
[Musik]
das gemüse wird geputzt und geschnitten
die kartoffeln werden geschält
es wird gekocht und gebraten beim
personal essen bespricht das team was
für diesen tag wichtig ist günther und
astrid sprechen über weitere details die
ersten gäste kommen und werden von
günter begrüßt
zuerst gibt es etwas zu trinken während
in der küche schon das essen zubereitet
wird
[Musik]
günther serviert das essen und wünschte
den gästen guten appetit
[Musik]
mehr über den beruf des restaurant
fachmanns erfahrt ihr im nächsten teil
[Musik]
wir müssen doch mal gerade überlegen wir
hatten ja heute die regierung für die
überraschungsmenü was wir den gästen
machen
du kannst was hast du da vorschläge mit
vorspeise ich prüfe und zucchini so
etwas machen wir das was machst du fünf
leicht ich habe mein fähnchen brust
kartoffel strudel und danach haben wir
das mal überlegen
ich habe per paypal für das mit dem
schmecken die hatten
sonderwünsche war da nicht bisher nicht
aber noch irgendwas kommt sie fragt ja
nochmal gar nicht bescheiden wir heute
mit den genetischen haben wir das
überraschungsmenü dann haben wir glaube
ich ein geburtstag für vier minuten und
die bestände bei aller karten dann
machen wir
glosse 18 habe ich einmal alle
gegenseite alles im menü und wenn nach
sonstige sonderwünsche kommen sind wir
dann noch eine chance
[Musik]
restaurant schon 1000 überlesen guten
tag
hamburg
wie viele personen
zwei personen das klappt um welche
uhrzeit möchten sie kommen morgen
19 uhr der name war fußball mit tz
ja wie ist der vorname dann wollte ich
nur eine telefonnummer
0 17
hab ich dann drin morgen abend 19 uhr
für zwei personen hatten sie den tisch
gestellt
ja gehts weiter so frech namen butzbach
alles klar
möchten sie drin lieber draußen sitzen
gerne draußen hat dann bekommen sie
bedanke
hallo und habe schon mal die karten
schön wär schon was zu trinken für sie
ein bisschen wein zum essen vielleicht
ich hätte gerne wie sting dessert
spritzig oder die waren bei stücken wie
wärs ein bisschen milder fruchtig dann
nehme ich den weißburgunder und für sie
auch ein glas wein wo sie vielleicht zum
hauptgang nämlich ein bier
wir haben ja alles klar
[Musik]
einmal das kölnisch schön habe ich für
sie dem wunder kann gerne meinen
schlitten probieren
ja
haben sie schon entschieden dass sie
essen möchten ja ja ja das dürfen wir
ihnen bringen
für mich gerne die berater die wird
ohnedies zubereitet ja wir können müssen
das dressing ändern weil öl drin ist
aber dass kein problem das kriegen wir
hin gerne für sie für mich bitte die
gurken joghurt milch sollten ja gerne
bei ihnen auch irgendwas worauf sie
achten müssen irgendwas was sie nicht
vertragen und dem hauptkamm was darf ich
ihnen damit bringen
für mich an das 2 ich hätte das
hauptgang gerne den kalbsrücken ja mit
pfifferlingen und den kalbsrücken gerne
rosa machen wir ja gern alles klar
einmal den sommer für sie
wir haben den geschmeckt war alles in
ordnung
ja sehr gut danke danke
möchten sie noch mal ein bisschen wie
bisher karte werfen wieder soweit alles
in ordnung war alles gut oder wir hätten
gern die rechnungen ging alles klar
bringe ich ihnen gerne zusammen party
jahre habe ich schon
die geheimzahlen mit ok bestätigen
[Musik]
gleich neben belegt mache ich ihnen
fertig beieinander
der gast steht hier immer im mittelpunkt
und das ist halt wichtig dass die leute
zudem zum gast anfang an offen und
freundlich sind es kommt natürlich auch
sehr sehr viel fachwissen noch dazu über
das essen muss man bescheid wissen das
heißt wenn die teller am pass stehen in
der küche muss man direkt sehen was es
ist also man muss verschiedene
fleischsorten kennen verschiedene
gemüsesorten kennen
man muss sich mit wein auskennen muss
nachher wissen welcher wein passt zu
welchem essen weil das gehört halt auch
dazu dass man die gäste berät also es
kommt auch noch sehr sehr viel an
fachkenntnis nun gerade im bereich es
nun bringen aber auch wichtig ist die
kommunikation im team
sowas muss jemand der hier arbeitet
natürlich auch können wenn man noch gar
keine erfahrung hat kann man
gucken ob irgendwo einen aushilfsjob
meinetwegen angeboten wird wo man dann
an gelernt wird nur dann wird man
gelernt für das was in dem restaurant
gebraucht wird und wenn man sich dann
dazu entscheidet eine ausbildung zu
machen
dann ja dann geht halt lustig es ja noch
die berufsschule mit dabei um die ganzen
theoretischen sache zu lernen und die
praxis lernt man dann im betrieb wichtig
ist halt dass man den betrieb findet der
zu einem passt und dass man dann auch in
den betriebsarzt und zu den kollegen und
ins team einzige nachteil ist die
arbeitszeit dass man halt viele am
wochenende arbeiten muss und auch viel
abends arbeiten muss also wenn
geburtstagsfeiern sind dass man auch mal
keine zeit hat um dahin zu gehen
die vorteile sind dass wirklich jeder
tag anders ist dass man sehr viel
abwechslung hat in dem buch also man
macht zwar jeden tag das gleiche aber
dadurch dass jeden tag andere gäste da
sind manchmal hat man zehn ethisch
manchmal mein geburtstag manchmal eine
hochzeit also ist wirklich jeder tag
läuft komplett anders und das macht halt
super spaß die gäste sind
normalerweise echt nett und was auch
richtig viel spaß macht es wenn die
gäste mit schlechter laune kommen und
mit guter laune und da geht